just at the top and thank you so much
for taking the time to sit and chat with
me about the show i i was of a i'll say
formative age when the prequels came out
so this is a distinct pleasure for me to
get to chat with you oh cool
um
and and i'm wondering for you you know
back when you were filming those movies
you didn't get a a significant time
spent in the vader suit this i would say
is definitely a step up in that regard
um but did you also get an opportunity
to work on your darth vader voice i'm
assuming you got the chance to kind of
do a little dialogue on set
um
yes but you know we we we we always knew
that the voice was was had to be you
know james earl jones's voice uh it's
such a a critical part of this character
um so so
i i knew that was going to be the case
but you didn't have any kind of anything
that was distinctly different maybe from
the anakin the anakin persona anything
you kind of tried to infuse
that was a little different
um yes uh but i don't i don't want to
get too specific with it yeah uh
so so we're you know still more episodes
to come and
you know we'll leave it at that okay
um we've already gotten a pretty pretty
early clash between kenobi and vader
and i know that
when you came back to this series there
was a lot of kind of getting back into
the the training of it all the fight
choreography that kind of thing how did
it how did the training process differ
this time around even for maybe like
episode three
sure well episode three i i there was a
tremendous amount of sort of
fight scenes that i had to learn uh
so i i
there was just a lot of training on that
on this one there was as well um but
maybe not to the extent that there was
on episode three but just coming back
and and getting to you know go to the
the
the training gym and you know swing a
lightsaber again it's just a blast we've
definitely already gotten a little bit
of a peek
at you outside of the suit it looks like
a pretty intensive makeup process talk a
little bit about what that is like in
terms of the prosthetic work
sitting in the chair like how early do
you have to come to set on those days
i'm just curious as to how that all kind
of takes shape yeah i mean um it's a
good four to five hours uh
getting all the prosthetics put on and
um
i got to work with a great team of
uh makeup artists uh
led by a fellow called sean smith and um
they did they did some you know
incredible work it was it was
you know uh
a lot of times sitting staying very
still while they glue layers of you know
prosthetics all over your body but i
really enjoyed just the the
the visual creation that took place
every time um
and it's you know it's so much sort of
affects the way that you feel and
and
and you behave when you see yourself
like that so i i enjoyed it i'm sure you
can't say much um about what's to come
but is there anything that you can kind
of tease for fans from the last couple
episodes and what we can expect from
from vader
well there's not much i can say um
but but uh i think i think fans are in
for a good last couple of episodes
all right that's fair um i'm all out of
time but thank you so much for for
taking time out of your day to sit and
talk about the show it's been great so
far and i cannot wait to see the
conclusion so thank you again